It is time for Drew's News.
The only news that feels like finding
a four leaf clover every day, hopefully.
And with me at the desk, my little shamrock, Ross Matthews.
Hi, everybody. Hi.
Happy Saint Patrick's day.
It is Saint Patrick's day
so I guess I can't pinch you Rossi,
because you're wearing green.
I am wearing green and look, I have a beard.
I haven't had a beard since high school.
She was a sweet girl.
(Drew laughs)
I bet she was, Rossi.
Look at that.
Hi, everybody.
(audience applauds)
Happy Saint Patrick's day, everyone.
Now 54% of adults are celebrating today.
And Rossi, guess economically speaking
how much money people are spending on this holiday?
I have no idea.
Hold on to your leprechaun hat, Rossi,
because Martha Stewart Magazine reports
that people will spend $5.87 billion.
What? What?
So I'm like, what?
It's a lot of, you know,
alcohol, and shamrock shakes, and bar business.
And listen, this is good for the economy.
The average person will spend about 42 bucks
on everything from green clothes, to corned beef,
and green beer.
So hey, happy Saint Patrick's day
and happy boost to the economy.
Well, yeah, I think...
(audience applauds)
5.7 billion seems like a lot,
but when you break it down to like $42,
yeah, like I bought this green shirt.
I didn't have a green shirt,
but I knew I wanted to wear a green shirt, you know?
I love the color of that green.
It's got a lot of blue and it's very attractive.
Thank you. Thank you.
All right, hey, next up, anyone here watch "Fleabag"
with Phoebe Waller-Bridge?
(audience applauds)
Well, if you love that show, great news.
Hollywood Reporter says Amazon just green lit...
Green lit on Saint Patrick's day.
Green lit her next series.
Details are under wraps a little bit,
but it shoots later this year.
And remember, "Fleabag" premiered on Amazon
way back in 2016, and it cleaned up at the Emmy's.
It won six of 'em.
And since then, Phoebe has been super busy.
She launched "Killing Eve," which I'm obsessed with,
with Sandra Oh.
She co-wrote the latest Bond movie.
And now she stars opposite Harrison Ford
in Indiana Jones five.
(Drew gasps)
I know. I know.
And she has a brand new project coming.
She really is the cat's pajamas.
Yeah, she is.
I cannot wait to see the show.
I need Phoebe Waller-Bridge.
I'm on the feeder.
Hurry, hurry, hurry.
Yeah, yeah, uh-huh, I could.
I started it, and then I just watched
too much "90 Day Fiance."
It's like everything else just gets back seat.
Do yourself a favor, Rossi,
and get on the "Fleabag" thing.
God, it's just so good.
Okay, I'm sold.
(upbeat bright music)